dans l'amazonie française le stage forêt
entre dans sa dernière semaine et sa
partie la plus redoutée la survie
les hommes sont désormais livrés à eux
mêmes
ça c'est fort de tout rires on va
confectionner avec ça elle est à briques
de se protéger de pelé et une secte qui
tombe
l'ennui avec un équipement réduit au
strict minimum
les soldats ne peuvent maintenant
compter que sur eux mêmes sam prépare
son bivouac à l'aide de sa seule
machette
c'est pourtant fait pour récupérer pour
faire mon abri mon abri personnel et
après ça j'en récupère une deuxième jeu
sur vire
emilio n'est pas mieux outiller la soupe
les quais mon coco rico
après trois semaines d'instruction
les militaires passe de la théorie à la
pratique ont-ils assimiler les rudiments
de la survie en forêt chacun y va de sa
technique
le légionnaire nicolas et a presque
terminé sa tanière moi c'est mon petit
lit tranche des coloris avec le petit
rien moi ça me plaindre petite maison
première mission réussie pour nicolet il
peut se concentrer à présent sur la
nourriture à cette heure avancée de la
journée
pas le temps de chasser ni de péchés il
faut se rabattre sur l'essentiel
choquée la nature a de plus simple à
offrir pour manger avec irait tout temps
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ouvrir la télé ça qu'on met
pour sa marque
beaucoup d'efforts fournis et à la dure
pour au final n'obtenir qu'une minuscule
tranches de palmier au bout peu agréable
de l'as partant bien pétain apparemment
c'est ça mais elle doit être pour
beaucoup mais d'autres en sont encore à
préparer leurs abris comme le
légionnaire elia team de préparer mon
lit mon lit de fortune
je suis un peu en retard mais je vais y
arriver
eliaquim perd beaucoup de temps avec son
projet très ambitieux mais déjà les
matelas qui sont là que je veux couper
en deux par la suite je vais transposer
comme ceux ci ça sonnera comme un
brancard brancards mais au moins on doit
pas partir c'est toujours mieux on évite
les scorpions est vite les insectes
de son côté remis de sa blessure à la
main pierre s'attaque à un autre
impératif imposé par les instructeurs le
feu on sachant que le taux d'humidité en
guyane dépasse les 80%
il suit vient juste de pleuvoir à
lokeren arrive c'est très très compliqué
c'est de l'impatience un curé jean c'est
un peu comment la pêche une heure
d'efforts pour y arriver
pierre peut enfin souffler
que demander de plus dans ce contexte
c'est royal ces menaces et là je suis
chaud saint georges
je suis au plaza mais très vite il est
appelé par sam asie vient justement avec
ce singe dans les parages les deux
hommes ont peut être trouvé de quoi se
nourrir
il se met en chasse
ici le singe n'est pas une espèce
protégée
tu nous tiens
dans sa voix
à l'aller la chambre
j'ai pas autant de secteurs autre raté
la première tentative ne sera pas la
bonne 1 500
[Musique]
là
mieux ailleurs
tous mangent dans la selva tout se mange
dans la jungle
sauf justement les singes interdit par
les instructeurs comme ces vecteurs de
beaucoup de maladies il préfère pas
prendre de risque mais nous filent le
poids du singe henry donc là il doit
faire un kilo et demi
on va voir 800 g de riz 1 kg pour
traverser un bon 800 g k mauvais du tout
du riz qu'ils ne récupéreront que le
lendemain
en attendant chacun doit se procurer sa
propre nourriture pour pierre ce sera un
repas très léger une bon coeur de
pommiers jeu fruits sont forts de la
flotte pierre se contentera de l'eau
contenue dans les fruits
pour d'autres c'est la corvée 100 mètres
à parcourir dans la nuit pour trouver la
première rivière lot et boueuse mais
elle guînes ne fait pas la fine bouche
le bon coup j'en ai un brin de toilette
pour les uns
et dès que possible pour toute la troupe
le repos du guerrier
il est à peine 19h30
la plupart des soldats dorment déjà
presque tous ont l'estomac vide
un réveil à la lumière du jour pierre et
sam s'activent
ils attendent d'une minute à l'autre
l'arrivée des instructeurs pour une
inspection générale ils vont tout
évaluer l'abri le lit le feu et le cas
tous ri un sac à dos de survie pas
simple a confectionné avec des feuilles
de palmier et il est difficile de se
concentrer quand les premiers effets de
la fin se font sentir
même sa troupe de m'immerger de l'année
je me lève la tête qui tourne déjà les
voit on les entend plus pareil il ya ce
soit mika ou pire qui parle je comprends
pas leur voix au niveau de louis saha
lui c'est en ça c'est une première pour
moi
sorti de nulle part
le sergent chef débarque au bivouac et
le capitaine samuel vont tout passé au
peigne fin
vous touchez ployant ses camarades la
baie comeau a rajouté des feuilles c'est
trop tard vous êtes hors de position et
vous bougez pas l'heure du verdict pour
les soldats la note d'aujourd'hui est
capital pour l'obtention du brevet final
donc la toiture épaisseur la jeune après
si l'europe
un policier est rousse sur les feuilles
ça cool était mouillée donc c'est pas
bon là les fourches trop petit là le
plancher j'en parle même pas t'as même
pas la moitié avec des petites perches à
la con qui sont pas maintenus donc là
c'est pas bon il est où ton feu le feu
est éteint
j'avais dit qu ailleurs le feu il est
allumé quand j'arrive donc là c'est pas
bon
plus sévère encore dans son jugement le
sergent-chef tôt match solide
c'est solide ça cette technique de
réalisation et vient des eaux là
madagascar pour emilio comme pour les
autres rien n'échappe à l'instructeur
aucun défaut n'est tolérée ça c'est pas
la technique nous vous accueillons à
vous avez montré la mère patrie c'est
quoi ta pa trouvent être les liens dans
la forêt équatoriale
c'était pas bon oui sous les bretelles
laissant des sous-stations ok mais cela
donne sans bretelles le sac est inutile
impossible de transporter quoi que ce
soit dans la jungle manque des bretelles
de ce spéciaux une mangue le fond des
sacs une petite moyenne 1 mais encore la
survie commence plutôt mal pour les
militaires et ça ne fait que commencer
à 11 heures ils sont rassemblés sur
ordres du capitaine deuxième jour de sa
vie là vous êtes perdus gillet avant de
démarrer cette nouvelle épreuve
le capitaine samuel récompense les
chasseurs de la veille
hier le petit salle et a été tué 600 g
donc 600 g de riz g50 dorée aux
chasseurs fou 600 g légèrement moins
qu'espéré par pierre et sam chacun pour
sa gueule mais un bon repas en
perspective tout de même pour deux et
aux deux seulement
aujourd'hui la mission est de parcourir
6 km en pleine jungle
objectif rejoindre leurs nouveaux camps
pour s'orienter
seule la boussole et une carte le départ
est donné
ils ont trois heures pour rallier le
nouveau campement
[Musique]
dans la forêt amazonienne
aucun point de repère pour s'orienter le
moindre écart de trajectoire peut leur
faire perdre de longues heures dans la
forêt pour éviter cette situation
dangereuse dans les stagiaires se
concertent régulièrement sur le trajet à
parcourir et c'est le légionnaire junior
qui prend les choses en main
tu devras tout droit
mais très vite la tension est palpable
sam est en désaccord sur l'itinéraire
emprunté
tiens toi ce que tu as fais toi sur la
carte
mais là ça a changé la scène 1400 en un
millième pas se faire chier si ça fait
comme la rivière de tout à l'heure on va
pas se faire chier et on s'est fait
[__] ta gueule écoule ses 1600 x
jusqu'à la fin vous me faites pas chier
bon on est bien là vas-y je fais là toko
je suis maintenant chez que je reposerai
avec des pros quand je rentrerai pour
corser la faire les équipements sont
lourds
les ventres sont vides et la chaleur est
accablante
après deux heures de marche premier
malaise le légionnaire sergei vient tout
juste de rejoindre le stage
même le bon dieu opérateur radio ils
assurent pendant la survie une maison de
secours en cas d'urgence
en effet sergei est victime d'un coup de
chaleur
il n'est pas le seul à souffrir à
l'arrière mohamed n'avance plus il
ralentit la marche ce qui énerve le
groupe quelque chose s'y met on appelle
un hélico j'avance comme ça mais tout le
monde et greta garbo comme ça et loto à
l'espace de vente depuis début août en
fardeau pour la section n'allait pas
subir les frasques quad et moderne à la
pire arrivait à la fin de la marche est
un calvaire pour le soldat mohamed
arrivés à destination une heure plus
tard à bout de forces
l'épi en feu il est mis au pied du mur
par les instructeurs
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait si je te
ramène à la boxe et puis les stages
jugeant que c'est loin d'être fini le
stage de nokia c'est pile combat où
c'est mieux comme ça ça se rétablit pire
montre alors parce que là ce n'est pas
capable de marcher ses ballades de
kilomètres pour rejoindre la pirogue
encore je vous en bas je vous ramène pas
après le prochaine étape c'est retour à
pau en fin de stage et cheikh mohamed
craint le pire
c'est le moment le plus redouté par les
soldats la sentence que va prononcer le
capitaine qui m'était rogers allez tu
vas venir at me happy rock fini qui veut
arrêter encore car mal aux pieds le
stage est pas fini vous n'avez pas de
pied le stage ça me fait mal au coeur
[Musique]
dames 1
le coup d'essayer quand même impossible
non tu peux pas
tu peux pas marcher
j'ai défendons plus cool val était comme
ça à seulement cinq jours de la fin
l'aventuré s'arrête pour le légionnaire
mohamed j'évacue un stagiaire là qui
peut plus marcher la lékié qu'on demande
de l'élu pause les soldats ne sont plus
que 30 à rester en course il ne marche
que j'estime à 2h30 3h grand maximum et
nous la résidence 16h50 heure de
questions ce stagiaire ralentissent les
les activités ça les jours à venir tout
je préfère tout de suite l'arrêter il a
les pieds ravagée par les mycoses ses 5
août il sera incapable de possibles
eustache dans les mêmes conditions
jusqu'au dernier jour
le stage de la légion n'offrent aucune
chance aux maillons faibles les soldats
vont devoir à présent puiser dans leurs
dernières ressources pour continuer la
partie survie
à peine arrivé à leur nouveau campement
ils sont immédiatement à pied d'oeuvre
leurs nouvelles missions construire des
radeaux pour être capable de se déplacer
sur le fleuve première tâche allait
chercher du bois sur l'autre rive
alex fait de sa fille
tout le monde s'active le légionnaire
eliakim s'occupe des lianes comme les
autres il est affamé
ce n'est pas ne te pas céder surtout
qu'en allant de ventre par un pays qui
est le cargo et chaque minute
il fait les trois anciens comme ça après
chaque fois qu'on trouve quelque chose
donne envie de le manger et on a mûri
même l'afrique est devant moi là j'ai
envie de le manger mais bon quand même
parfois j'ai mes limites
même les plus endurcis comme nico montre
des signes de faiblesse bonjour qui ne
mangent pas tous n'ont qu'une idée en
tête terminer au plus vite pour chasser
et pêcher avant la tombée de la nuit
sans la moindre énergie ils ne sont plus
que l'ombre d'eux mêmes avec la fin
les esprits s'échauffent vite chacun
reprochant à l'autre de ne pas en faire
assez pour détendre l'atmosphère sam
préfère partir à la recherche de
nourriture
avec pierre ils vont à la pêche aux
crabes
s'il rentre bredouille il n'y aura rien
à manger au bivouac ce soir au show
avoir comme environ dans leurs trois
objectifs en rapporter suffisamment pour
toute l'assemblée affamés qui compte sur
eux hu a donc crabes des marécages une
petit goût salé
moi j'aime bien meilleurs que prévu très
goûtu à la nuit tombée de retour de
chasse
pierre n'a pas encore eu le temps de
faire goûter ccravh il s'est blessé à
l'oeil
l'infirmier jérémy n'arrive pas à
soulager sa douleur voire rien du tout
mais rien du tout l'aquitaine et je peux
pas le faire mais le problème je te dis
si c'est un truc est passé derrière le
jeu pendant des mois au pire je mettrais
un truc comme ça j'ai cerné en chine
sauf quand un mini camp parce que on
verra demain pour pierre une seule
crainte ne pas pouvoir aller au bout de
l'aventuré
mon frère deux fois il a chaud que des
copeaux de bois dans la loi comme ça
qu'à l'hôpital très influent dans la
ménagère à l'hôpital langage mais un
tâche et je suis miss acheteurs foutent
rien si foxes bord les filets devant lui
je finirai comme généralement il dieu
nous a donnée deuxième politique quand
tu fermes ta technique est bien là sous
verre il va descendre
[Musique]
[__] ça me fait chier tu te fais un
truc comme ça
ah ouais mais j'ai pas le choix mon
coeur je trouve que c'est dégueulasse
j'ai trop mal mais c'est un truther
[__] ça me casse les couilles un oeil
de merde
jeanny marc joly mort au rouge répéter
une fille si j'avais testage pourtant je
me pète avec le chef avec l'officier
tout
sam s'inquiète pour pierre son ami
tiendra-t-il le coup jusqu'à la fin en
attendant au camp les soldats peuvent
enfin profiter du butin de sam et pierre
faute de mieux
les crabes rencontre leur petit succès
de crabes
enfin de l'aude est cramé du sel sans
partage avec tout le monde
le repas a été truquée
après
alors pour oublier la fin rien de mieux
que de finir la soirée avec un chant de
la légion
me
soudés autour du feu il est maintenant
temps pour les soldats d'aller se
coucher
[Musique]
demain malgré la faim et la fatigue
ils devront de nouveau répondre présent
il fait à peine jour quand commence la
nouvelle épreuve
ce matin les soldats doivent regagner le
centre de la légion avec les radeaux de
fortune qu'ils ont construits ils seront
une nouvelle fois prono mettrais est
évalué c'est bon
première étape mettre les radeaux à
l'eau ce qui provoque rapidement de
nouvelles tensions
c'est le moment de vérité les radeaux
vont-ils tenir le choc
si ce n'est pas le cas ce serait un
échec pour l'ensemble du groupe
la mise à l'eau est une nouvelle source
de stress
jusque là pourtant tout va bien les
radeaux ont l'air de flotter
maintenant le plus dur reste à faire
coordonnées la nage pour atteindre plus
vite le point d'arriver sur la ligne de
départ
trois équipes les stagiaires ont 45
minutes pour parcourir les deux
kilomètres qui les séparent du centre
d'entraînement tout le monde est à cran
car l'évaluation et collective
salou
[Applaudissements]
après
quatre jours de survie et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont encore la patate sauf que le
groupe qu'il a appris tout droit et sans
visite qui avec la marée qui de son set
le défi de traverser
après 40 minutes
c'est le groupe du caporal pierre qui
atteint le centre d'entraînement en
premier
aulas aller au bord de l'eau
les seconds ralenti par le courant ont
finalement réussi le challenge à dix
minutes d'intervalle
filles c'est physique on est plusieurs y
en a qui sont pas trop bon nageur dans
le groupe
il faut toujours qu'il y avait ceux qui
nagent pas trop bien mais ensemble on
s'en sort toujours
on a perdu une petite longueur au début
par deuxième groupe mais énervé jusqu'au
bout pas manger hargneux on a tout donné
on arrive le premier après quatre jours
la partie survie est terminée
les stagiaires vont enfin goûté à l'or
vrai premier repas une soupe composé des
restes de la cantine du centre
d'entraînement pour les soldats sa
famille un vrai menu cinq étoiles très
délicieux j'ai l'impression que c'est la
meilleure et pas de ma vie je n'ai
jamais mangé une sorte aussi bon qu'avec
une telle envie folle à la même ma mère
n'a jamais aussi bien cuisiner de toute
ma vie je crois
vingt litres de soupe liquidée en moins
de dix minutes le plein d'énergie pour
la dernière ligne droite
cinq jours long et éprouvant qu'ils
effectueront au sein du centre
quelques échauffements avant l'épreuve
reine du stage
la terrible piste jaguar vous avez 45
minutes pour les français furent loire
[Musique]
une dizaine d'obstacles à première vue
insurmontable
uniquement franchissable grâce à
l'esprit d'entraidé de cohésion du
groupe
pas le choix c'est une évaluation
collective de nouveau chaque obstacle
doit s'effectuer en un temps limite pour
le capitaine samuel la sphère est mal
engagée là on le voit c'est parce qu'ils
ont fait la une seule sangle au lieu
alors qu'ils en ont 4 de pouye aucun
escaliers construit on voit que les
stagiaires les derniers n'avaient pas
passé
le chrono tourne il ne reste plus que
cinq minutes
un soldat doit encore franchir le mur
au delà de la partie physique c'est tout
la partie commandement qui nous
intéresse
cette incapacité à trouver les solutions
pour franchir les obstacles et surtout
surtout les faire franchir mais mon
préféré
tentative de la dernière chance
[Musique]
in extremis le stagiaire passe
l'obstacle
l'épreuve est réussi mais ce n'est
qu'une mise en jambes deuxième parcours
un passage sur des pieux humide et
glissante
le groupe d'emilio à exactement vingt
minutes pour le franchir les stagiaires
déséquilibré par leur équipement passe
l'un après l'autre
pour l'instant les hommes passent sans
trop de difficultés il n'en reste plus
que trois le chrono affiche 13 minutes
quand soudain avec cette chute
le légionnaire mais tout le groupe en
difficulté car il doit recommencer
maintenant c'est au tour délia kim de se
lancer une chute douloureuse mais pas le
temps de s'apitoyer sur son sort
[Musique]
appareil hakim tout le groupe parvient à
franchir l'obstacle encore je dois bien
avec t'amuser la pression est sur lui
eliaquim n'a pas droit à un deuxième
échec comme ça tu vas être déséquilibré
à l'effet sablier ne sont pas pouvoir
comme toi mouvement heureusement 12 mois
attention elle avait besoin de vous je
prends les deux fois les longs à la
toute dernière seconde
le groupe d'emilio échappe à
l'élimination les poteries et en plus
tendues sous ma couette et ce matrice à
l'intérieur du coup je ne suis pas la
capacité
mais j'ai fait avec gecimed ans et avait
la pression de réussir son deuxième
passage
oui la pression ici on serre les dents
on ferme le cerveau et ses seins avant
quoi s'est passé après pendant ce temps
l'équipe menée par le caporal pierre est
elle aussi en plein effort à l'exemple
vous
sur les épaules des hommes un tronc
d'arbre de plus de 350 kg seule manière
de réussir se relayer sans faire tomber
le trou au niveau de son côté le groupe
des millions n'en a pas fini avec la
bourre il aborde même la partie la plus
redoutée de la piste jaguar les
objectifs le plan incliné à première vue
cette infranchissable
oui 90° n'existe pas si les gens bien
nés là-bas
allez
radi demandé d huile au delà on avance
mais adaptateur à tous les soldats ont
20 minutes pour passer l'obstacle pour
la
allez tu là cette année la belgique en
montrant ghoul attention à bien des
égards et les règles sont très strictes
a dit là-bas à s'y attendait de vous
voir vous assis toi
[Musique]
un parent au prix de tant d'efforts
les soldats viennent à bout de cette
épreuve mais la piste jaguar leur
réserve encore quelques surprises
[Musique]
à venir sur plus de 100 mètres
un parcours du combattant où les soldats
doivent rampe et entre les barbelés
un véritable chemin de croix
e
chaque mouvement est un effort sans donc
en lice et dans la boue les soldats
progressent au ralenti ce livre a aussi
salué le début
trente minutes de calvaire pour venir à
bout de la piste jaguar après l'épreuve
une douche fa sont légion
matériel tour
l'heure est à la récupération et au
grand nettoyage
tout doit être parfait les uniformes
comme l'équipement thomas comme tombe
bien le foot reçu
ils ont peur
pour quelques heures
les hommes ont enfin quartier libre et
ça fait du bien de se reposer un peu là
et surtout de se réapprovisionner en
nourriture du manger 4 à son lot de
pitch pareil ça va faire deux heures
qu'on est là j'ai déjà mangé 4 à sion
après ces quelques instants de répit les
soldats entame l'ultime ligne droite du
stage spécialistes forêt pour leur
dernier jour des preuves
ils sont acheminés par pirogue ils vont
naviguer pendant une dizaine de
kilomètres
une fois débarqués ils vont devoir
rejoindre le centre d'entraînement au
pas de course jusqu'à la dernière minute
les stagiaires vont en baver et c'est
l'instructeur luiz qui est à la
manoeuvre
ok on a environ 7
l'intéressé entre 6 et 8 km c'est la fin
des veaux d'étal qu est alors arrivé là
bas auquel chaque kilomètre c'est au
moins en moins en moins pour le finir et
star jockey alors on s'accroche tout le
monde on s'accroche l'époux faible et
basdevant il maintient la cadence
on reste tous groupés ok les famas
hockey un imprévu va rendre la course
encore plus difficile
tout le monde élève les chapeaux on a
tous
on n'a pas parce que deux soldats ont
oublié leur chapeau quand on est fort
mais tu es toujours la course se fera la
tête découverte pour tout le monde
tous dans la même galère à la légion on
est solidaire
il fait 35 degrés les hommes cours
durant les heures les plus chaudes de la
journée
bombay
luis donne la cadence et accompagne
jusqu'au bout les légionnaires
[Musique]
si les auteurs y donnent pas l'exemple
d'une demande comment une fois tu es
toujours au niveau il faut toujours se
préparer il faut toujours être les
meilleurs parmi nous
poule à le groupe secor jusqu'au bout
botha futur
pierre et sam permettent un légionnaire
en difficulté de terminer la course
cana qui ont lentement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le dernier kilomètre à pleins
poumons tu l'écris de la légion
m
[Applaudissements]
et en terminant avec cette course il les
en finisse aussi avec le stage
[Applaudissements]
un mois d'efforts souvent sur humains et
à la clé une victoire pour ses trente
hommes qui ont tenu le choc
[Musique]
voilà apparemment c'est fini jusqu'au
réintégration
ça c'est fait
nous donnait tout pour arriver jusqu'à
la fin sur numérique
malgré les fatigues du tour chaleur je
sais pas je sens qu'il y aura les masses
et liberté c'est ça le plus important
j'ai la réponse en phosphore blanc dans
la tête ou dans son cabas et c'est parti
c'est le stage de plusieurs côtés faire
jusqu'à maintenant oui jusqu'à
maintenant oui c'était les produits
difficiles qui j'ai fait la vérité
reste encore à connaître le classement
un dernier stress et à chaque fois je
[Musique]
sais quoi c'est ça qui munich mutins non
mais je sais jusqu'où je me la faim la
fatigue et les blessures paraissent déjà
loin avant même la proclamation des
résultats de cette aventure de quatre
semaines dans la jungle les hommes ne
retiennent plus que la réussite
ils l'ont fait ils sont allés au bout
d'eux mêmes et ils en sont très fiers
stagiaire et instructeur pour une même
foi dans le même cadre à la nuit tombée
voilà le moment de vérité
l'heure des résultats les hommes font la
queue devant le bureau du capitaine
samuel c'est maintenant au tour des
millions
e
quand on avoue selon capital un rapport
aux avocats guitare tu n'es pas bon tu
es tu as raté la formation de bûcheron
que 7 sur 20 ans bûcherons et du coup
c'est ce que l'application est les
éliminatoires du sras breveté
aguerrissement et j'ai rien à reprocher
sur l'état d'esprit tu avais les
chevilles enflées au bout des huit jours
ça aurait plus de mettre en échec
tu as voulu continuer ta richesse
rétablir d'affecter jusqu'à la fin du
stage par contre tu repars pas qualifiés
pas brevetées tu comprend bien pourquoi
europe 1 est ce que tu as des questions
tu peux disposer emilio est allé au bout
du stage mais son rêve de devenir
instructeur forêt ne se réalisera jamais
même verdict pour elia keep hope they
pas brevetées tu attendais ok tu es
échec également sur les deux parties un
bûcheron encore plus 6 nous ferons pas
ce que pointe kevin est jugé trop
dangereux
les navigations parce que le pire est
que ça va pas je pense que tu es
quelqu'un de pa manuel dans la vie il ya
deux catégories de gens les manuels les
intellectuels toi tu peux partir des
manuels auquel j'ai fait un compte-rendu
où j'explique que tu étais peut-être un
peu jeune en service pour faire ce stage
c'est un stage long difficile talent
mais reid et aller au bout ok parce que
c'était un stage physique ce un stage
rustique et au départ c'était pas gagné
je pense moi quand je t'ai vu arriver
j'ai pensé tout est en open semaine et
pourtant tu as vu tout un bon état
d'esprit
tu t'es accroché et a quand même le
mérite des tableaux de matisse
rapportait aguerrissement ok je fais
poser pour un échec qui n'est pas
vraiment une surprise pour lui
eliaquim et déjà fier d'avoir tenu
jusqu'à la fin de l'aventuré
sur les trente rescapés 24 soldats ont
décroché le précieux brevets parmi eux
les inséparables pierre et sable tout
sourire au moment des adieux avec le
capitaine samuel
fêtard et ex j'ai pas son droit
direction courroux la base du 3e
régiment étranger d'infanterie
après deux heures de route et de sommeil
réparateur arrivé au quartier général de
la légion en guyane
pas
dans les chambres et les soldats se
mettent sur leur 31
uniformes impeccables coupe
réglementaires ou est-ce que c'est
difficile devant le miroir les corps
apparaisse marqué par l'intensité des
efforts et les privations
moi j'ai maigri dit qu'ils étaient avant
des stages 92 la géci à 92
en tenue d'apparat les légionnaires
n'ont qu'une hâte connaître leur
classement
verdict dans quelques minutes après la
traditionnelle levée des couleurs en
voyait enfin le grand patron arrive il
va découvrir qui sont les recrues les
plus valeureuses en commun repos
proclamation des résultats
classée première avec une moyenne d 16
72 le grand gagnant
le légionnaire brésilien junior 3e à
loin derrière le serbe nicolet qui
termine troisième capra chef pierre et
sam finissent quatrièmes et cinquièmes
duo de choc jusqu'au bout bien je
félicite tous ceux qui ont réussi le
stage aujourd'hui vous verrez une
connaissance approfondie de la forêt
équatoriale
le stage vous donne un certain nombre de
compétences ceux qui n'ont pas réussi le
stage je sais qu'un acquis sans échec
quoi qu'il en soit rien n'est perdu
ce que vous avez appris vous le savez et
même si vous avez échoué sur un stage
propulse east tout ce que vous avez tout
ce que vous aurez appris à côté vous
serez capable de le mettre en oeuvre au
profit de vos sections brassard
fin de la cérémonie
direction le foyer pour un cocktail
emilio commencent à relativiser son
échec les vrais vais je suis content de
l'avoir terminé c'était ma fierté
d'homme je vous dis depuis le début on à
faire taire
comme j'ai raté dans beaucoup de
domaines je n'ai que le reggae la soul
mais c'est beaucoup mieux ça que rien du
tout voilà je pars quand même la tête
haute
du côté des brevetés pierre et sam
savoure ont visé pas vraiment classement
déjà on est arrivé dans le top 5 je
pense que ce job sur la touche comme ça
bush se contente de ce qu'on a ça suffit
encore plus fort sur le podium le serbe
nico oui je suis content ça va je sais
que j'aurai aussi des stages je savais
pas qui jouait troisième je sais que je
gagnais peut-être à frire les plantes 5e
16e je serai pas mais là je suis enfin
la délivrance leurs familles ne sont
qu'à quelques mètres mais avant de les
retrouver
dernier geste symbolique déposer les
armes
demander si précieux
finexs charles 37 de la france a mangé
dormir
[Musique]
après quatre semaines dans l'enfer vert
pour pierre les grandes retrouvailles
[Musique]
bien c'était bien
qu'est-ce que je suis tout mais ça me
lui aussi retrouve sa femme
sept des loups le plus
je pu voir un petit peu et
[Musique]
ça a été oui ça issue tout en lui dieu
oui même pas vous imaginer c'était très
longue c'était dur mon mari m'a beaucoup
manqué et puis je pense qu'on est tous
dans le même cas et que c'était super
dur moralement
donc même pour moi c'était dur de le
soutenir
donc voilà enfin il est bien bien
amaigri mais bon il va bien bien se
reposer la semaine prochaine tous les
deux en vacances qu'on va en profiter
voilà ouais ça m'a aidé de pensa marine
pendant ces quatre semaines
marine le fini
la famille tout ça ça va bien aider à
chanter les femmes de pierre et sam
viennent de faire connaissance elles
pourront dorénavant se soutenir lors des
prochaines missions de leur mari c'est
déjà prévu dès la semaine suivante
[Musique]
une voiture votre mail west
moment